[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us
as americans is far greater than what
divides us
this morning we introduce you to
photographer brian bowen smith that's a
cool name like so many artists and
entrepreneurs
his business just dried up when the
coronavirus hit so that's when he
decided to hit the road in his vintage
truck
to document a country under quarantine
so along the way he photographed the
famous names you know
there's reese witherspoon and the
blended family of demi moore and bruce
willis there they are
and as meg oliver shows us that's good
but he also captured the spirit and the
soul
of everyday americans my name is brian
bowen-smith i'm a photographer
and i traveled over 11 000 miles across
the united states of america
in my ford f-100 documenting what's
going on during this covet crisis
good and freeze good
as you were driving across the country
what does america look like
during a quarantine beautiful but
on the other hand i was seeing it empty
with no one walking around per se i was
seeing it in a sad
time as well with all these restaurants
and the hardware store all boarded up it
broke my heart
you would see these uplifting signs as
well yes
he took a lot of pictures of the smiling
faces
there was a family in that pickup truck
the dad is
holding his uh friend and the mom's got
the little baby in the back
almost everyone that i shot was so happy
to see me
it did bring joy this photo
truly was a gift for everyone
the mom positioned him and then he put
his arms around his brother
and then his brother grabbed his hands
and i just shot the picture got chills
the doctors you see the nurses and you
took off the mask for a second and you
see the lines and they're like i'm so
glad you're doing this and they start
crying
[Music]
thank you new york the coast to coast
we did it
what did you learn from this journey
about our country during a crisis
i think our country is coming together
the one dairy farmers
we went to it's literally like we won't
make it
the neighbors from down the street were
coming and helping
the farmers and the family make their
farm work
during a crisis when you see people like
that unite how does that feel knowing
you captured those
and it made me feel like uh we're gonna
be okay
i think that our country is super strong
our country doesn't want to go down
but our country also i think loves each
other
at the end of the day they're going to
bind together and do
what we need to do
[Music]
wow thank you very much brian bowen
smith we just saw a picture of common
standing in front of a sign
i always like color pictures but all the
photographers always say
black and white really shows the power
and you certainly see that
tony looking at his work so well done
gave me goosebumps looking at some of
those pictures
i know very well done very interesting
to hear that he thinks that we are
coming together as a country i guess
when you're taking a black and white
photo you push out all the noise all the
color you
you see things very simply and sounds
like good news to me if you think things
are getting better you know it's a great
idea to travel
all across the country and take pictures
just from a truck
very powerful stuff